before we find louisiana republican
senator medical dr bill cassidy
who's part of the bipartisan working
group that's rolled out the two main
proposals senator i appreciate you being
with us and taking a
brief respite from working the phones uh
where are we exactly
so the majority leader mitch mcconnell
spoke today
he sounded optimistic they're narrowing
down the numbers of
issues that are really sticking points
down to one or two
i do anticipate based on what i've been
told that we will have a deal by this
evening
and probably vote on it sometime
tomorrow we've
we've heard for so long from a number of
folks up on capitol hill i'll take the
republican side for
for just a minute but from mitch
mcconnell how important
indemnifying and dealing with
coronavirus
lawsuits are for businesses and
protecting lawsuits from liability
protecting businesses from liability and
now that appears as though it may or may
not be in the bill people seem to be
willing to
give up so much right now just to get a
bill did
does that sort of call into question how
necessary those things were
so we had a working group of four
five democrats four or five republicans
the republicans advocating for that sort
of liability relief
for this last year when the guidelines
were very unclear
but democrats really didn't want to go
there and whatever we offered still went
too far for them
in terms of liability relief now
democrats wanted state and local aid
we linked those two together but
nonetheless although we had a deal on
state and local
we never got a liability at some point
you got to declare a victory and come
home and we were
just we got what we could we got three
for the employers for the employees for
the unemployed
we couldn't get liability relief we have
to work on that next congress there
seems to be this riff
uh in in the senate right now over
these additional checks you've got josh
hawley uh saying he wants
twelve hundred dollar checks another
round uh siding with bernie sanders uh
hard to find two people who conceivably
would be
farther apart and then your colleague
ron johnson said this last night take a
listen
this is all borrowed money against our
children's future and we would have more
money left over to target relief to the
people who really need it right now look
at all the small businesses that didn't
get
loans didn't get relief look at the
number of people that didn't do that so
congress it's easy to shovel money out
it's just easy to just
pick a number and and say let's spend
that it's a little
more difficult to actually look at the
numbers figure out the best way to
target this
and that's what doesn't happen very
often here in congress fair critique
fair critique i'll say what senator
sanders and senator hawley both said
that they would oppose money going to
small employers to keep people
employed and oppose money going for
unemployment for those who are
unemployed
and money going for food relief and
money going for rental relief
and helping landlords too because we
didn't get checks
now the checks are okay but the folks
who are really hurting
are the folks who are about to lose
their business and laying off folks who
otherwise would be
employed i say the best stimulus check
is a paycheck
so i think there's a little bit of a
different philosophy there
if we can you know if checks are part of
the deal they'll be part of the deal
i think ron johnson's point was let's
take care of the folks who are really
hurting
the unemployed the folks about to lose
their business and therefore folks about
to lose their jobs
when you've got a republican and josh
hawley uh advocating for this and
president trump has talked about checks
as well
uh just just sending out money to
everybody
is have republicans sort of lost the
north star of fiscal conservatism
so those two do not define all all of
conservatism uh nor all of the
republican party
right so we have to first and there's
always going to be diversity of opinion
now those checks are stimulatory people
are going to spend that money
and that does increase sales tax revenue
and keep stores afloat that sort of
thing
i'm not arguing there's not a benefit
there but if you're talking about the
folks as who are of greatest need
they are the folks about to lose their
job because the person who owns a small
business is about to go bankrupt
so if we have to choose where we help
first let's help the folks about to lose
their job
about to go bankrupt because i think
that neil cavuto asked
such an important question earlier of me
and i admit that
the only answer i could give is it's
2020 and anything can happen but
that caveat aside i'll put the same
question to you
which is is there any way there's not a
deal
by tomorrow by tomorrow are we going to
be going
another few days on this i think there
is a deal by tomorrow
uh what would this what would derail a
deal i'm sorry
what would you provisions that folks are
striving to get
common ground on compromise which would
be what
um there's a there's a little technical
but the under the cares act the federal
reserve was given this ability to lend
money to businesses right
we felt as republicans that was an
emergency issue
now that the emergency is resolved for
the bigger businesses we should stand
that down
democrats wish to keep it kind of a
technical point
but it's a sticking point right now well
in such an important one you can just
imagine how the markets will react on
monday either way
uh to that uh in terms of in terms of
looking at how businesses are going to
be able to survive and
get more loans from the federal
government i shouldn't say survive but
get more money from the federal
government which uh certainly changed
things
senator we appreciate it and we'll let
you get back to the phones and to work
thank you very much appreciate the time